madame la présidente madame et messieurs
mais monsieur le président de commission
mesdames et madame et monsieur le
ministre mesdames et messieurs le
rapporteur chers collègues depuis 2010
est le président de la république a
dessiné des objectifs de transformation
majeur pour la france notamment en
matière d'économie d'emploi en matière
de finances publiques ou en matière
d'écologie de protection de
l'environnement avec lui nous pensons au
groupe démocrate que c'est dans la durée
que nous pouvons agir de façon
substantielle sur ces sujets là il nous
faut planifier construire des stratégies
de moyen long terme pour relever les
défis auxquels la france et les français
sont confrontés
mais regardez le chemin au loin ne sert
à rien s'il on trébuche sur le caillou
qui est à nos pieds et c'est à l'image
de la situation que nous traversons sauf
que ce n'est pas un caillou mais un
énorme bloc de granit qui a surgi du
fait de la reprise post pandémie la
guerre en ukraine
nous voulons du pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaire pour les français car le
plein emploi la montée en compétence la
réindustrialisation c'est du moyen terme
à court terme il doit faire face à une
inflation forte qui rongent leur pouvoir
d'achat et compliquent drastiquement le
quotidien nous devions y répondre nous
l'avons fait en agissant pour tous pour
ceux qui travaillent avec l'augmentation
du smic
les modalités de restructuration dans
les branches professionnelles les heures
sup le doublement ou triplement de la
prime pouvoir d'achat ou encore
l'évolution du point à 10 dans le plfr
pour ceux qui ont travaillé avec la
revalorisation des retraites de 4%
rétroactivement au 1er juillet pour ceux
qui sont les plus fragiles et les plus
modestes avec la réévaluation des apl du
rsa de l'allocation adulte handicapé
sade et conjugale isation mais aussi les
prestations familiales
pour les consommateurs en facilitant les
résiliations de contrats ou en contenant
l'augmentation des loyers
nous voulions aussi décarbonés
massivement et rapidement le
fonctionnement de la société française
en agissant sur l'isolation de nos
logements l'arrêt des motorisations
thermiques et le développement du mix
énergétique à base de nucléaire
d'énergie renouvelable c'est du moyen
terme à court terme nous at on des
mesures d'urgence pour que tout
simplement
les français puissent se chauffer
l'hiver prochain et que notre économie
en partenariat avec celles de nos
voisins européens puissent fonctionner à
celles et ceux qui poussent des cris
d'orfraie parce que nour et autorise on
s'attend volt a fonctionné ou parce que
nous permettons la mise en place d'un
méthane est flottant nous agissons en
responsabilité car il n'y aura aucune
transformation écologique profonde
possible si le pays est bloqué
nous voulons aussi rétablir l'équilibré
des finances publiques et des antennes
et à la france c'est du moyen terme
à court terme ces 20 milliards qui sont
actés dans ce projet de loi pour limiter
les effets de la crise et notamment
celle de l'inflation car nous ne
réformerons pas la france si nos
compatriotes sont submergés par les
difficultés du quotidien
finalement et pour paraphraser un
chanteur populaire notamment auprès des
plus jeunes vouloir réformer c'est
simple et le faire avec les français
devraient être basique
déclamer des bonnes idées c'est simple
construire des majorités de projets pour
les faire adopter de bataille de basic
cela était le cas et que les différents
groupes d'opposition républicain tomek
la majorité sénatoriale nous le salon et
nous en félicitons
le groupe démocrate se réjouit de ce
texte tant par son contenu que par la
forme du débat qui a eu lieu nous sommes
convaincus que cela peut être une
méthode pour la suite
garder le cap des réformes tout en
tenant compte des difficultés du moment
et travailler au delà de la majorité en
confiance et en partenariat khl sénat
simple et basique je vous remercie